[Music]
happy Friday welcome back to certified
country I'm Sylvia lacy and here at ET
we are gearing up in full force for the
60th annual Grammy Awards hosted by
James Corden the Grammys will air live
from New York City on Sunday January
28th on CBS as always it promises to be
a star-studded evening of epic
performances but I've got some bad news
for us country fans
none of our favorites have been
nominated in the main categories this
year so I'm really bummed about that but
I am here to break down what we can
expect from the big show
most of the genre specific winners will
be revealed during a pre telecast
ceremony so you won't be seeing them on
TV but here are my predictions and while
we're here go ahead and let me know
yours in the comments below for best
country duo/group Performance my money
is on a little big town they previously
took this category in 2012 with pontoon
and 2016 with girl-crush I think they're
gonna do it again in 2018 with better
mass
[Music]
[Applause]
as for rest country song this one is
really really hard but I think butter
man could take this one too this time
though the award would go to the
songwriter not the artist so actually
Taylor Swift would be the winner here
thank you good news here win or lose we
will still definitely be seeing a little
big town during the telecast since they
are slated to perform lb T is also up
for the honor of best country album
against some heavy hitters personally I
would love to see Thomas Rhett score his
very first grammy with this one but my
gut is telling me to go with chris
stapleton here and from a room volume
one
[Music]
now here's what you will see on TV best
country solo performance there is no
doubt about it
alison krauss is a favorite among Grammy
voters but for the last two years it was
Maren Morris and Chris Stapleton who
took this category I'm gonna bet on
Maren Morris again here and her first
number-one hit I could use a love song
[Music]
Maren will also lend her voice to a
special tribute performance honoring the
victims of the route 91 harvest festival
tragedy brothers Osbourne and Eric
Church will also perform
[Music]
[Music]
when it comes to the glam these nominees
are sure to bring it I am really looking
forward to seeing what Miranda Lambert
chooses for the red carpet Karen
Fairchild in Little Big Town always
bring their fashion a game and I am
positive that Thomas Rhett and his wife
Lauren will be serving up couples goals
meanwhile Sam hunt he has a knack for
the unique fashion-forward kind of look
alright y'all thank you so much for
watching be sure to tune in to
Entertainment Tonight and ET online.com
for the latest Grammy news and come back
and see us again next week right here on
YouTube for a very special live episode
of certified country with a very special
guest we'll see you then
[Music]
you